tampa bay race case it is right-hander
brent honeywell jr september the 19th of
2017 with his last game that actually
counted and this has been a long time
coming you have to believe that he is
pretty amped right now dwayne we saw him
in spring training for an inning and
that was something but this this is a
whole nother animal and you know that
heart is pumping good two up two down
aaron hicks will be the hitter swinging
a ground ball again right into the shift
to yandy diaz he'll go to the bag
himself and beat hicks and that will
retire the side a nice nifty one two
three
top of the first for brent honeywell jr
in his major league debut jordan
montgomery you look at his one start and
it was impressive six innings six
shutout innings to not walk anybody and
struck out seven meadows a left-hand
hitter
is eight for thirty oh
that was a fastball that ran up and in
and got him in the shoulder i wonder if
there was any intent and now marty
foster
is
pointing to both dugouts and issuing
warnings now that kevin cash can't be
too pleased about that they know the
history of these two teams now joey
wendell got hit yesterday in the fifth
inning and the rays have not answered
back at all
so we'll keep an eye as we move along so
with a runner at first two outs here's
mike mike hitting 125 with a homer and
two runs batted in drives water deep to
left field gardner just turns around and
watches this one land in the blue seats
mike cenino with his second home run
of 2021 and the rays take a two nothing
second any lead
well the the change up zenino does a
great job of going out getting around it
with his power
and that ball drilled brent honeywell jr
top step
and this is how the rays over the last
couple of seasons have answered the
yankees just go out and beat him on the
field so the yankees get a base runner
and here is arshella
deep to centerfield and i'll go back on
the track at the wall see
a long home run for geo
game is tied orchestra two geoaschella
the most happy fella
and he ties the game at two 453
really yeah that's a blast 404 to dead
central and it ended up on top of that
wall
they are loaded up
it could be two there's one
there's two a run does score before they
needed that double play yankees lead 3-2
and here is a rosarina who homered
yesterday randy rosarina lifts a
high-fly ball into right with some carry
judges going to go to the wall and that
baby is gone
with an offensive field homerun and the
rage retake the lead
he was able to get in on the better part
of the bat than brandon lau did and it
looked like a classic back spun homer
with some carry and it
landed in the front row well the
celebration is on in front of that
raised dugout
will the adamux get into their
duet so two down and here is austin
meadows oh look out pitch close close
and it got him i think
so meadows will head to first again
that's four tampa bay rays that have
been hitting the series the first one
was a little iffy as far as i'm
concerned this one i don't think he
threw it
thompson coming into a bit of a messy
situation here with the bases full of
yankees
what a tight spot lemay who is usually
nails where the base is loaded also slow
rolling towards third picked up by
paddle the second one rousso's turn they
got him double play
side retired
three double play from padlow to brusho
to diaz and ryan thompson bails out the
rays who maintained the lead
you got judge at second the tying run
though thompson a right-handed dias to
torres drive it is a basic
to left field judge is coming home the
throw is not in time
it is a big rbi single for glaber torres
and the game is tied at four
labor torres shortening up a little bit
with his swing the line drive to left
field was curious with the rose arena
and left to phil nevin the third base
coach would send aaron judge he does and
the throw way off line labor torres
first rbi of the year is a big one so
here is geo
who has a two run home run
rounded up the middle and
[Applause]
there goes three shell going for two and
he's gonna make it that is a double for
geo orchella and his hustle is huge in
this situation
gardner's the runner at third la mayhew
at second
and
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
wow how about that
and gardner just might have run the
yankees out of the inning he got stuck
in no man's land cena was able to pick
it out of the air and throws it to kevin
paddle who runs down gardner to tag him
out to gone
and now the pitch swinging a grounder to
short fielded by willie sets his feet
throws and we're gonna go to the bottom
of the knife still tied with two outs
mike can get a
little head start he goes on contact
padlow though has had trouble putting
the ball in plays over three with three
strikeouts cut out and missed at 100
upstairs
so padlo strikes out for the fourth time
chapman gets through the ninth no runs
one hit one left so the runner hicks
moves to third and that brings up o'dore
set up to be a hero in his first yankee
game that one is looped into center
field that is going to be in there for a
base hit in front of phillips scoring
his hicks
and a big
rbi single for odor and the yankees take
a 5-4 lead as torres moves to third and
the yankees have first and third with
chew out and that will bring up gary
sanchez swung on and hit hard up the
middle there's a basic center field
glebe torres scores and the yankees have
a two run lead it's a base hit and an
rbi for sanchez he drilled a single
right up the middle a ribby single and
the yankees now take a 6-4 lead that's
amazing how you can relax a little bit
after a big two-out hit from odor
sanchez gets that slider middle of the
plate doesn't try to do too much with it
right back up the middle
and that is a base hit to right field by
urshella and it gets by more go and
it'll go to the wall odor scores sanchez
is coming home he will score the throw
to third is not in time and the yankees
lead eight to four
two out heading continues hershela
having a huge
afternoon marco can't come up with it
abreu is not a fast worker he's ready to
go three and two to meadows
the pitch swung on and hit high in the
air to center hicks is there aaron
makes the catch ball game over yankees
win the
yankees win